en gros c'est comme dans la zone
espoirs
l'everest
pour les peuples de l'himalaya son
homologue omar la déesse mère du monde
pendant plus de trente ans la montagne à
résister à toute tentative de conquête
la première de ces tentatives date de
c'est une expédition britannique dirigée
par charles ce blues belle histoire de
l'everest commence bien avant cette date
durant le grand relevé trigonométriques
de l'inde durant les premières années du
19e siècle
l'everest n'ai connu que sous le nom de
piques numéro 15 un sommet recul et
mystérieux à cheval entre le népal et le
tibet mais en 1851
les relevés topographiques effectué à
partir de l'inde l'établissent comme la
plus haute montagne du monde
mais l'ue connaissant aucun nom indigène
les géomètres la baptise everest en
l'honneur de serge aux ir est ancien
directeur du bureau trigonométriques et
géodésique de l'inde
moitié du 19e siècle au début des années
20 les vrais stress tard violet
inexploré et inconnus le népal et le
tibet garde ta leur jalousement leur
isolement et ferment leurs frontières
aux étrangers jusqu'à ce qu'en 1904
soeur francis younghusband n'obtiennent
du dalaï lama quelques droits d'accès au
tibet dans des buts d'exploration et de
commerce
mais il faut attendre les années 20 pour
voir les premières tentatives sérieuses
de conquête de l'everest en 1921 une
petite équipe d'alpinistes de
scientifiques sous la direction de
charles howard bris organise une
reconnaissance du côté nord l'année
suivante une expédition est mis sur pied
par le général charles bruce
l'isolationnisme du népal force
l'expédition est longue marche départ de
d'algérie il doit traverser le royaume
du sikkim puis les plaines arides du
tibet avant d'arriver à shekhar tanga
monastère forteresse visité pour la
première fois en 1921 par l'équipe de
reconnaissance à partir du monastère ils
prennent la direction du sud verture
book est la vallée du rhône au voc
au centre de la vallée se trouve le
monastère de rangoun
construit à 5000 mètres d'altitude c'est
la dernière habitation permanente avant
l'everest 25 km plus au sud
le camp de base était établie plus haut
dans la vallée au pied du glacier de
wrong book de là l'expédition se fraie
un chemin jusqu'au flanc même de la
montagne entre le 1er et le 13 mai les
hommes effectué une reconnaissance du
glacier et établisse une série de
contres 5200 mètres et 6400 mètres
l'équipe s'attaque ensuite au col nord
entre le pic noir et l'everest lui même
le 19 mai un ultime camp est installé
sur le col à 7000 mètres
le lendemain l'expédition se lance pour
la première fois à l'assaut du sommet
la première équipe composée d'êtres
humains fred de george mallory de ward
somme bel edward norton atteint une
altitude de 8000 230 m un record qui ne
tiendra que quelques jours une deuxième
tentative utilisant cette fois de
l'oxygène a lieu le 27 mai geoffrey
brousse et georges fringe dépasse à
cette occasion de 150 m leur corps de
leur camarade
mais ses exploits ne sente obtenu qu'au
prix de grands sacrifices morsay des
blues souffrent de gelures et
d'épuisement doivent être transportés au
pied de la montagne au cours d'une
tragique troisième tentative
cette chaire pas perdre la vie dans une
avalanche sous le col nord
en 1924 une seconde expédition se lance
à la conquête de l'everest
cette fois ci l'équipe d'alpinistes
compte huit hommes dont quatre vétérans
de la tentative de 1922
fidèle à une tradition militaire edward
norton colonel d'actifs dans l'armée
britannique est nommé à la tête de
l'expédition george mallory est désigné
premier de cordée brossé présent tout
comme ce malware l'équipe est complétée
par noël audel john deere hasarde est un
jeune alpiniste inexpérimentés andrew
irvine qui connaîtra un sort funeste
suivant la proche désormais classique
d'expédition installe son camp de base
dans la vallée de round rock et elle
établit des camps intermédiaire jusqu'au
col nord
mais dès le départ l'ascension est
freinée par des tempêtes de neige très
violente pour la saison les alpinistes
doivent attendre la fin du mois de mai
avant de pouvoir atteindre le pôle nord
la stratégie de l'automne et d'établir
une série de caen sur l'arête qui relie
le col noir au sommet le camp cinq à
sept mille huit cents mètres le camp six
à huit mille 100 m et le camp 7 à 8
milles 320 m
deux tentatives différentes seront
lancées l'une du camp 700 oxygène et
l'autre du camp 6 avec oxygène
le retard dû au mauvais temps a
néanmoins eu un effet bénéfique
inattendu
pendant une grande partie du mois de mai
le camp de a servi de camp de base
avancé
en conséquence les alpinistes ont passé
plusieurs semaines à plus de 6000 mètres
et il se sent très bien acclimaté à la
haute altitude lorsque l'assaut du
sommet est lancée pendant le mois de
juin le 2 juin la première tentative
parsemé revel et norton atteint 8 milles
550 mètres un record d'altitude d'autant
plus impressionnant que les deux hommes
utilisent pas d'oxygène
la seconde tentative a lieu deux jours
plus tard par mallory et et ruinent le 8
juin noël audel installé au camp 6 ans
soutient croit les apercevoir assez haut
sur l'arête nord est à environ huit
mille six cents mètres
c'est la dernière fois que l'on verra
les deux hommes
personne ne sera jamais si mallory et
erwin n'ont réussi à atteindre le sommet
tout ce que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'endroit où ils ont été vus pour la
dernière fois est situé plus haut que le
point atteint par l'antenne et aux
merveilles
mallory et robin ont donc établi un
record d'altitude qui ne devait pas être
battus avant près de trente ans un fan
et s'écoulent avant qu'une autre
tentative de conquête de la grèce ne
soit organisée cette fois ci par une
nouvelle génération d'alpinistes
l'expédition de 1933 dirigé par leurs
hôtes l'âge est la plus importante est
la mieux équipée jamais monté jusque là
l'itinéraire choisi est en grande partie
identique à celui suivi par l'expédition
de 1924
plusieurs camps sont établis entre le
monastère le col nord ce dernier est
atteint le 15 mai et deux camps
supplémentaires sont installés sur
l'arête nord
deux tentatives sont lancés vers le
sommet la première par percy winner is
et laurence la guerre la seconde par
franck smythe et eric shipton les deux
cordes et échoue à l'endroit même où
norton a dû rebrousser chemin en 1924
en 1936 rutledge tente une nouvelle fois
sa chance sur l'everest à la tête d'une
équipe très solide
au départ le temps se montre favorable
après avoir établi quelques camp
intermédiaire sur le glacier
le col nord et conquis le 15 mai mais
l'expédition de 1936 ne pourra pas aller
plus loin
en effet la mousson s'abat sur la
montagne quelques jours plus tard
recouvrant l'everest d'une profonde
couche de neige molle et instable
l'expédition ne peut plus progresser et
abandonne 2,4 en juillet les hommes sont
de retour en inde épuisé et démoralisé
victimes d imprévisible conditions
météorologiques de l'himalaya la
dernière expédition d'avant guerre est
organisé par eric shipton et bill
thilleman
contrairement aux expéditions de 1933 et
1936 elle est de petite taille mais
composées presque uniquement de vétérans
comme franck smythe et n'aurait l'odeur
l'expédition de 1938 est resté dans les
mémoires pour plusieurs raisons
tout d'abord sa petite taille lui permet
d'être peu coûteuse at un quart du
budget de celle de 1936 ensuite c'est la
première ascension réussie de la face
ouest du col nord enfin c'est l'une des
tentatives les plus héroïques jamais
réalisé pour conquérir l'everest
comme en 1936 la mousson est précoce
mais les hommes persévère parfois dans
les conditions les plus atroces
le 6 juin à caen minuscule était habits
très haut sur l'arête nord mais les 600
derniers mètres on était rendu
infranchissable par la neige et les
alpinistes doivent rebrousser chemin
après trois jours dans les profonds des
traîtres congères de la face nord
treize ans plus tard eric shipton
revient sur l'everest
cette fois à la tête d'une équipe de
reconnaissance photographique chargé
d'étudier la voie sud les années
écoulées ont été le théâtre de grands
changements après des siècles
d'isolationnisme le népal a enfin ouvert
ses frontières aux étrangers tandis que
la chine a fermé celle du tibet shipton
et son équipe effectuent leurs approches
par le sud traversant des territoires
allard inconnus aux occidentaux
dans la vallée de l'adour cosy shipton
aperçoit pour la première fois la face
sud de l'everest
il traverse la région de cela comme vous
le pays des sherpas et en septembre
une fois la mousson terminé il arrive
enfin sous les flancs enneigé du massif
de l'everest
shipton a pour missions précises de
faire la reconnaissance du no 2 vallées
connu sous le nom de west comme ces
malaurie qui l'a découverte en 1921 lors
d'une reconnaissance mais aucune
évaluation précise n'avait pu être
effectués depuis le lointain tibet
depuis sa position méridionale shipton
découvre que la coume est un cirque eux
quasi parfait c'est une vallée profonde
et circulaires enfermé comme dans un fer
à cheval par l'epic qui l'entourent des
flancs du lhotse jusqu'à l'entrée de la
vallée à l'ouest des sens un immense
glacier débordant de la coume tel un
torrent de gigantesques blocs de glace
durant le mois d'octobre l'équipe de
shipton fait des reconnaissances poussée
de toutes les approches possibles de la
face sud est comme prévu le seul
itinéraire viable passe par la cascade
de glace qui mène à la courbe
shipton se rend compte que bien car du
et dangereuse la casquette de classe
n'est pas infranchissable à cascades
sera d'ailleurs la clé de la conquête de
l'everest des buts de l'itinéraire
classique qui permettra dans les années
suivantes les ascensions les plus
réussis de la montagne en 1952
c'est une équipe suisse qui profite la
première des découvertes de shipton les
suisses ont obtenu l'accès exclusif à
l'everest pour le printemps et l'automne
1952 1953 est réservé à la grande
bretagne et 1954 à la france en
conséquence les préparatifs d'anglais
pour l'expédition 1953 sont effectuées
avec la plus grande méticulosité le
monopole britannique sur l'everest
appartient au passé
1953 pourrait bien être la dernière
chance pour une conquête britannique
l'expédition la plus chère jamais
organisé et doté du meilleur matériel
disponible chaque pièce de l'équipement
est soumise aux tests les plus
exigeantes
les tentes les vêtements sont testés
dans des conditions du mal à yenne
simuler c'est-à-dire dans des vents
dépassant les 170 kilomètres par heure
les bottes chaudes et imperméables sont
conçus pour être à la fois solide et
légère
ce sont les rations de nourriture qui
bénéficie des progrès les plus innovants
les expéditions précédentes se
nourrissait en majorité de conserve
mais les boîtes de conserves sont
encombrantes et difficile d'emploi en
montagne on met donc au point un système
d'emballage sous vide assurant légèreté
et solidité
l'encombrement est encore réduit en
s'assurant que dans la mesure du
possible salle des rations sèches seront
transportés durant la traversée du népal
à l'automne 1952 les dernières
préparations touchent à leur fin est le
colonel john kent est nommé à la tête de
l'expédition
le choix de jeunes officiers d'activé ne
fait que souligner la détermination
britannique
la tentative suisse a échoué il semble
évident que la conquête de l'everest est
à portée de main
la fille
au début du mois de mars 1953
l'expédition se rassemblent à katmandou
les britanniques qui rencontrent leurs
sherpas et leur serdar l'ordre en chef
d'anzhi glorieux
c'est la septième fois que dancing se
rend sur l'everest et cette expédition
marquera le sommet de son incroyable
carrière en 1935 le jeune tensing
faisait déjà partie de l'équipe de
reconnaissance par le nord emmenée par
eric hudson
il sert ensuite retraite jean 1936
tillman en 1938 et surtout les suisses
en 1952 lors d'une récente expédition
suisse dans le massif du gas oil tensing
s'est affirmé comme un sirh d'art doué
d'une endurance et d'une détermination
en tout point extraordinaire en 1952
les suisses ont d'ailleurs recruté
dancing non seulement comme sir d'art
mais comme membre à part entière de
l'équipe d'alpinistes avec raymond
lambert
il est monté bien au delà de 8500 m
égalant ou dépassant même l'exploit de
mallory
reconnaissant les indéniables
compétences de dancing et sa
connaissance de l'itinéraire sud
hunt recrute tensing comme l'avaient
fait les suisses c'est à dire comme sir
d'art et comme grimpeur le 10 mars
une fois les instructions données aux
sherpas et au porteur l'expédition est
prête à se mettre entre le volume
d'équipements et de nourriture est
énorme bien supérieur aux expéditions
précédentes
au point qu'il faut diviser la troupe
portes de caravanes
la première est constituée de 150
porteurs transportant le minimum vital
de l'équipement la seconde qui par le
lendemain compte pas moins de 200
porteurs mais ce chiffre est encore
largement insuffisant il faut attendre
un mois pour que la plus grande partie
de la nourriture et du matériel des kits
katmandou
crippen avait approché l'everest depuis
le sud mais ont choisi de suivre
l'itinéraire suisse en prenant la
direction de l'est depuis katmandou
contrairement au tibet où le paysage est
relativement à riz des plats
l'itinéraire qui traverse le népal est
aussi spectaculaire que verdoyant
peut-être la plus belle région de
trekking au monde
la géologie particulière de l'himalaya a
donné naissance à une incroyable
diversité de paysages de climat et de
culture l'himalaya à brides les
montagnes les plus hautes mais également
les plus jeunes du monde
elles sont le produit d'un glissement
géologique causée par le choc entre le
sous continent indien et la plaque
continentale asiatiques
les légendes locales parlent d'une mer
là où se tiennent aujourd'hui les
montagnes en effet les franges
méridionale du tibet furent à une époque
les rives d'une mère disparue depuis
longtemps la mère de téthys
au fil des siècles les îles de cette
mère grandir à une vitesse incroyable
de plus de 15 cm par an à mesure que
s'élever les montagnes la région située
au nord de la mer pris également de
l'altitude pour devenir le plateau
tibétain avec le temps le massif
himalayen devint une barrière titanesque
quasiment infranchissable par la mousson
indienne honneur la terre de vins un
désert tandis qu'au sud
elle s'épanouit dans le berceau dé aux
himalayenne
sur les contreforts sud la forêt
tropicale laisse graduellement la place
aux alpages des gorges apic traverse la
roche sédimentaire car les rivières
étaient là bien avant que n'apparaissent
les montagnes
de ce point de vue également les malaya
est unique car la ligne de partage des
eaux ne suis pas les contours des plus
hautes crêtes et chaînes montagneuses
comme c'est normalement le cas
elle suit en fait la frange méridionale
du plateau team et à l immense majorité
des rivières tracent leur lit à travers
le gigantesque massifs himalayens
apportant les pluies de la mousson
jusqu'aux terres fertiles du sud
pour l'expédition britannique
l'itinéraire n'est pas les présente à la
fois des avantages et des inconvénients
il est plus tortueux et plus ardue que
l'itinéraire 10 bêta et donc
impraticable pour les bêtes de somme
tout va être transporté à dos d'homme
met en contraste avec le mors de plateau
tibétain ses ventes glaciaux et ses
déserts arides
l'itinéraire n'est pas les traverses des
vallées profondes et boisé est franchie
d'école spectaculaire avant d'arriver à
la région de cela comme vous le pays des
sherpas
une fois ce point le paysage devient
plus nettement himalayens à l'ombre des
sommets majestueux les cultures se font
plus éparses et les villages plus
transitoire en effet les sherpas de cela
comme boum mène une vie quasi nomades
changeant de village et d'altitude en
fonction des saisons et des cultures
ils sont également d'un type plus
clairement mongoloïde que les
populations du sud
de même leurs cultures et leurs coutumes
rappelle celle du tibet le bouddhisme
règles presque tous les aspects de la
vie des sherpas drapeaux et moulins à
prières sont omniprésents comme les
tibétains les sherpas sont un peuple
joyeux et démonstrative
ses qualités ainsi que leur
acclimatation naturel haute vallée de
l'himalaya n'est pas les vents des chats
pas les meilleurs porteurs de très haute
altitude au monde capable d'en remontrer
aux montagnards occidentaux les plus
déterminés plus haut dans la vallée à
une altitude de 4300 mètres se trouve le
monastère de thiant mme bocher pendant
les trois semaines qui vont suivre
le monastère va servir de base à
l'expédition la réate y embaucher offre
une plage de récupération aux alpinistes
le trajet depuis katmandou a duré 16
jours dans une succession de montées et
de descentes vont prendre petit à petit
de l'altitude
beaucoup de membres de l'expédition se
sentent fatigués car ils ne sont qu'au
début de la phase d'acclimatation à
partir de tian bo chez le terrain va
désormais monter régulièrement un peu
plus haut dans la vallée la végétation
devient inexistante et à part quelques
rares d'oiseaux migrateurs
la vie est totalement absente car rien
ne peut survivre très longtemps sur les
flancs glace et des sommets himalayens
l'art est fourni l'occasion de procéder
à des essais et à des ajustements de
dernière minute sur le matériel
contrairement aux expéditions d'avant
guerre
l'oxygène est maintenant considéré comme
indispensable et même obligatoire à très
haute altitude la radio servira à
maintenir la communication entre les
camps les moins élevés ainsi qu'avec le
camp de base
la première tâche de 'vente est de
trouver un endroit sûr où établir le
camp de base aussi près que possible de
la cascade de glace
la mission est confiée à une petite
équipe dirigée par edmund hillary
un alpiniste néo zélandais qui faisait
partie de la reconnaissance de 1951 il
est accompagné de giorgio qui était
présent également en 1951 de quatre
nouveaux venus et de plus de 40 porter
leur choix se porte sur le site où
s'étaient installés les suisses assez
près pour avoir une bonne vue de la
cascade de glace mais néanmoins hors de
portée des avalanches et des glissements
de terrain
l'endroit est cependant loin d'être
idéales à 5500 mètres d'altitude
il est situé en haut du glacier
inférieur il va falloir creuser dans la
classe des plateformes pour les tentes à
travail épuisant et démoralisant les à
partir de maintenant tous les camps
reposeront sur de la glace ou de la mer
le luxe relative de tiru bauchet n'est
plus de mise durant ses préparatifs pour
le camp de base
l'équipe d'alpinistes entame une
reconnaissance de la cascade de glace en
explorant les gouffres et les
protubérances autour de son pied
la cascade de glace de combo est l'un
des endroits les plus traître de la
planète
elle recouvre un terrain en pente sous
jacent très raide
sous l'effet de l'inclinaison le glacier
se fend et se casse de plus la pression
des murs latéraux accentue encore
l'instabilité de la glace à mesure que
le glacier descendent des auteurs de la
com il est graduellement écrasé entre
l'arête ouest de l'everest et les flancs
du nook c'est ce qui en résulte est un
torrent grondant de grâce et de pierres
qui même s'il ne se déplace qu'avec une
lenteur infinitésimale et pourtant en
constante mutation
quelquefois graduelle et quelquefois
d'une soudaineté effrayante lorsque des
mini tremblements de terre déclenché une
avalanche de blocs de roche et de glace
c'est la cascade de glace qui a causé le
plus d'inquiétude acceptable
lorsqu'il l'a vu pour la première fois
il l'a trouvé ardu et dangereuse
d'autant plus qu'elle est sujette à des
normes fluctuations de température au
matin lorsque le soleil n'a pas encore
paru derrière l'épaule du look c'est le
froid est si intense que le risque de
gelures est énorme mais dans l'après
midi lorsque les rayons du soleil se
reflète directement sur la myriade de
plock chaotique du glacier la cascade se
transforme en fournaise sapant les
forces et la volonté déjà bien diminuée
par l'atmosphère raréfiée shipton essais
par deux fois de franchir à cascades
lors de la première tentative lui-même
et trois de ses compagnons manque d'être
balayé par une avalanche
il connaît plus de succès lors de la
seconde trois semaines plus tard
mais au bord de la coume il se retrouve
bloquée par d'énormes crevasses par
manque de volonté autant que de matériel
il renonce à les franchir
c'est pourtant la reconnaissance
effectuée par shipton qui permet aux
suisses tout d'abord puis sow
britannique de vaincre les imposants
rempart de la cascade de glace
bien que l'aspect et la structure de la
cascade change du tout au tout de saison
en saison
les caractéristiques générales en
demeure néanmoins les mêmes équipés en
conséquence les hommes se fraie un
chemin dans ce chaos m'ouvre
franchissant des crevasses insondable et
navigue entre des blocs vacillant et des
précipices à bissau
le 22 avril l'itinéraire est sécurisé et
balisé et deux camps supplémentaires
sont établis le camp 2 se trouve sur une
corniche relativement stable à mi chemin
du sommet de la cascade et le camp 3 sur
le bord de la wells co
dans la com le glacier s'élève plus
doucement de 6100 mètres sur sa
frontière ouest à 7000 mètres à sa
naissance
tout autour les pigs et crêtes du massif
de l'everest forme comme une enseigne
titanesque
cissé malaurie qui lui donne le nom de
l'ouest comme ce sont pourtant les
suisses qui les premiers pas vers le
biais dans cet endroit hors du temps
les wisps furent surpris par le calme
étrange de cette immensité en effet
troublée seulement par quelques tours
lyon devant et par les craquements et
grandement des avalanches
il baptise air cet endroit la vallée du
silence
une fois le camp 3 établi elle commença
le transfert des vivres du camp de base
jusqu'à là comme des balises rouges
jaunes et noir marquent la route des
cordes des échelles et des pompes
étaient installées sur les portions les
plus difficiles
l'ascension se déroule en deux phases la
première dans la section inférieure
jusqu'au camp 2 est la plus ardue la
seconde qui mène au camp 3 est
relativement plus aisés
en 1951 shipton avait reculé à l'idée de
mener des équipes de porter lourdement
chargés dans ce labyrinthe de glace
préférant s'attaquer à la cascade avec
des cordes est plus petite et très bien
équipé mais la mission de shipton n'est
qu'une mission de reconnaissance salle
de hand a pour but la conquête de
l'everest
de plus si l'expédition veut avoir une
quelconque chance de succès
trois tonnes de matériel vont devoir
être transférés jusqu'à la vallée de la
com de là il faudra encore monter 230 kg
jusqu'au col sud tout sera lancé
l'assaut final
la section inférieure de la cascade de
glace présente peut-être les plus
grandes difficultés
c'est là que la masse glaciaire et dans
l'état de décomposition le plus avancé
dans un processus de désintégration
progressive alors qu'elle descend dans
la gorge étroite coincé entre la crète
wes de l'everest et le nook sait
la salers et la réverbération
éblouissante de la lumière complique
encore davantage l'ascension déjà rendu
difficile par les blogs et les fissures
sous la surface
les hommes peuvent entendre l'incessant
mouvement de la glace un bruit
inquiétant et démoralisant par moment ce
sont des portions entières de
l'itinéraire qui partent en fumée et qui
doivent être tracée à nouveau dans un
environnement complètement différent
par chance l'expédition de 1953 ne perd
aucune vie dans la cascade de glace ce
qui ne sera malheureusement pas toujours
le cas lors des expéditions suivante
aucune autre portion montagneuse où que
cela soit sur la planète ne sait jusqu'à
aujourd'hui montrer plus meurtrière que
ce terrible et périlleux torrent de
glace morcelé
au dessus du camp 2 le glacier se fait
moins chaotique les blogs plus imposant
et les failles plus abyssal mais des
chutes constante de neige poudreuse
réduisent parfois la visibilité à
quelques mètres les traces pourtant
laborieusement creuser deviennent
difficiles à suivre et couche de neige
fine et instable recouvre traîtreusement
les crevasses
progression comparativement plus aisée
sur la portion supérieure de la cascade
de glace est ralentie par l'augmentation
de l'altitude
l'itinéraire grimpe avec régularité de
plus de 600 mètres les effets de
l'altitude se font encore plus sentir
lorsque l'on monte directement du pied
de la cascade jusqu'à la cour
les efforts de vienne épuisant et les
pauses se font plus fréquentes
c'est dans la moitié supérieure de la
cascade de glace que le rythme subissons
ralentissement le plus visible plus haut
sur les flancs même de la montagne
l'oxygène deviendra indispensable
ne serait ce que pour maintenir l'alluré
où même la plus modeste
une fois la cascade franchi l'ascension
redevient plus régulière et plus stable
le glacier est ici dans sa phase de
formation sa masse glaciaire recouverte
par une accumulation successives de
neige granuleuse fine et poudreuse
comme tous les glaciers que cela soit
dans les alpes ou dans l'himalaya
celui ci est enclin aux fissures latéral
mais les crevasses tu de la west coumes
sont relativement stables et facilement
franchissable dans la vallée de la com
la montée plus épuisante que réellement
difficile la profonde couche de neige se
tassent progressivement à mesure que les
équipes de sherpa navigue entre les
camps mais l'oxygène se fait de plus en
plus rare est le moindre effort est
accompagné d'une sensation
d'essoufflement le plan de hand prévoit
d'attaquer l'everest par la paroisse du
lot c'est ce qui inclut l'installation
d'une série de caen à partir du controis
on établit un camp de base avancé le
camp 4 à 6400 mètres
à mi-chemin du sommet de la coume le
camp 5 est installé à la tête de la com
et on prévoit de monter deux petits
camps 6 et 7
plus haut sur la face du lot c'est à
partir du concept une traversée apic
mènera au col sud sur l'arête sud est
d'où sera lancé l'assaut final
le camp 4 où sont rassemblés les
réserves de vivres et de matériel doit
servir de tremplin à l'adac dancing est
chargé de son établissement
c'est une tâche habituelle pour un sirh
d'art et cela lui permet également de
conserver ses forces pour la partie
cruciale c'est à dire l'assaut du sommet
pendant ce temps les alpinistes près par
l'ascension du lot c'est la face ouest
du lot c'est la 4e plus haute montagne
du monde est presque totalement
recouverte de glace
elles partagent beaucoup des
caractéristiques d'un glacier et son
inclinaison est trop accentuée pour être
vraiment défini comme un glacier c'est
plutôt un mur de glace à la surface
dentelées et parsemé de crevasses jouer
incessantes de glissements glaciaire
giorgio est le sherpa annie masson
chargé de tracer une voie jusqu'au
sommet du lot c'est en images se révèle
être un atout de grande valeur pour
l'expédition au cours des premières
phases de laventure il ne se distinguer
que par le nombre impressionnant de
cigarettes qu'ils consomment
mais sa contribution aux dernières
étapes les plus cruciales est immense il
montera plus haut que n'importe quel
autre sherpa à l'exception de tenzing
un autre cher parce distinguent
particulièrement au cours de la dernière
phase il s'agit du neveu de tenzing naw
hang guo
à 17 ans il devient le plus jeune
alpiniste à atteindre le col sud
quelques années plus tard il deviendra
le deuxième cherche pas à atteindre le
sommet de l'everest puis le premier
homme à le vaincre deux fois le lhotse
se révèle beaucoup plus difficile que
personne ne l'avait prévu l'ascension de
6700 à 7900 m est abrupte ardue et
extrêmement fatigant à cause de l'air
raréfié des hommes sont envoyés en
renfort mais le 19 mai bound commence à
perdre patience
le spectre d'une mousson précoce épée de
damoclès de toute expédition ne cesse de
grandir
le lendemain l'eau est un hymne à
redescendre
ils sont restés sur la face pendant neuf
jours et il entra c'est la majeure
partie de l'itinéraire
à part la traversée jusqu'au col sud
intrants voit alors wilfrid noël c'est
le sherpa hanul ou pour les remplacer et
tenter de se frayer un chemin jusqu'au
col pour augmenter leurs chances de
succès les deux hommes sont équipés
d'oxygène pour la dernière partie de
l'ascension
le 21 sous les rayons éblouissant d'un
soleil à son zénith en aperçoit na et
c'est à nous très haut sur la traversée
et se dirige rapidement vers la crète
le transfert du matériel vers le col sud
va pouvoir commencer
pour l'assaut final un camp doit être
établi sur le col à sept mille neuf cent
mètres d'altitude
temps et maintenant comptés et le
transfert depuis le cancer doit être
effectuée en une seule journée
pour la plupart des hommes il s'agit de
la dernière contribution à la conquête
de l'everest
une ascension éprouvante à des altitudes
extrêmes sur les contreforts et les
terrasses classé lui le sait
plus bas
dans la vallée du silence l'inquiétude
des derniers jours a fait place au calme
et à l'optimisme
il ne reste plus à franchir que la crète
sud est dont les deux tiers ont déjà été
explorée par les suisses
hunt a choisi de monter deux assauts
différent du sommet le premier par tom
bourdillon et charles evans utilisant un
système d'oxygène en circuit fermé conçu
par bourdillon et que l'on croit plus
efficace que le système commun en
circuit ouvert
malheureusement l'appareil va faire
preuve d'un manque de fiabilité qui
causera de très gros problèmes au cours
de l'ascension
l'équipe de soutien du premier assaut
est composé des rentes et de deux
sherpas d'annam kial et en tensing
ils vont précéder bourdillon evans au
col sud pour y établir le camp
les hommes quittent le camp 4 le 22 mai
vente et les deux sherpas précédent
bourdillon iweins ces derniers en de
vente la tâche la plus ardue conquérir
le sommet de l'everest depuis le col sud
en une seule journée
tandis que la première équipe prend le
chemin du col sud la seconde équipe
commencent les préparatifs pour sa
tentative
le soutien est composée de georges lot
et d'alfred grégory tandis qu hillary et
tenzing tenteront d'atteindre le sommet
de tous les membres de l'expédition seul
dancing est déjà allé plus haut que le
col sud en 1952 lambert et lui eurent vu
la victoire leur filer entre les doigts
et n sync est bien déterminé à aller au
bout de l'exploit
cette fois ci
grégory se met en route le 25 suivi de
peu par hillary et tenzing quoique
toujours d'une difficulté extrême
leur tâche est moins insurmontable que
celle de bourdillon rions
ils vont monter un petit camp entre le
col sud et le sommet ce qui leur donnera
un jour supplémentaire pour gravir les
derniers 900 m en arrivant au col sud
la seconde équipe retrouve end et dames
galles ils ont accompagné bourillon
evans sur une partie de l'ascension en
faisant la trace doute en transportant
l'attenté une partie des réserves
destinées à hillary et tenzing
aux alentours de 4 heures de l'après
midi bourdillon à ivan reviennent on les
avait vus quelque temps auparavant au
sommet du pic sud un point de l'art est
située à environ 100 mètres du sommet
mais personne ne savait s'il avait
atteint le sommet en lui même
les deux hommes sont de toute évidence
épuisé et hillary et tenzing se porte à
leur rencontre pour d'ions ivan sont en
effet atteint le pic sud ce qui est un
exploit part entière mais ils ne sont
pas arrivés jusqu'au sommet ils ne se
sont pas sentis la force de franchir la
dernière étape c'est-à-dire la crête qui
relie le pic sud au sommet et plutôt que
de risquer de subir le même sort que
mallory erwin ils ont pris la déchirante
décision de faire demi-tour dans que
cela leur était encore possible
tout repose désormais sur les épaules
d'hillary et de dancing la nuit suivante
le vent se lève mais ne se calme pas
lorsque le jour parlé
de toutes les crêtes arrivant au sommet
la crète sud est est la plus haute et le
col sud est à peu près 2000 mètres plus
élevé que le col nord il y fait beaucoup
plus froid
l'air y est encore plus rare évier et le
vent beaucoup plus féroce si la tempête
continue il n'y aura pas d'autre
alternative que d'abandonner la crète
mais le sort comme souvent au cours de
cette expédition tourne finalement leur
faveur
le 28 mai le temps redevient favorable
et la seconde équipe se préparent à
l'assaut
l'équipe de soutien composé de l'eau
grégory anglia ma part la première
ils doivent faire la trace et
transporter le matériel nécessaire à
l'installation de l'ultime bivouac aussi
près que possible de 8500 mètres et cela
en toute sécurité
hillary et tenzing partent plus tard
gardant leurs forces pour l'assaut final
l'équipe de soutien redescend en fin
d'après midi épuisés ils passent la nuit
sur le col
le lendemain grégory angama prennent la
direction de la coume et de son relatif
confort
seule l'eau reste sur le col
l'an demain est une journée d'attenté
d'angoise on scrute les pendre du sommet
de l'everest pour tenter d'apercevoir
une trace des deux grimpeurs mais plus
haut le dénouement est proche
plus tard il a ri d'écrire à la dernière
ascension depuis le pic sud jusqu'au
sevrage à 929 kameni créer un buzz
penderie à crespin de bell canada en sol
d'origine quantité notable des
il est 11h30 du matin en ce 29 mai 1953
le rêve s'est réalisé le colossal effort
de l'expédition reçoit sa récompense
surplombant la série de camps depuis la
cascade de glace jusqu'au col sud
les drapeaux du népal de l'inde de la
grande-bretagne et des nations unies
flotte au gré des incessantes rafales
hillary et tenzing passe la nuit au col
sud avant de redescendre dans la caune
de lendemain georges lot est en tête de
la cordée est suivie d' hillary et de
tenzing comme il approche du camp 4 lots
montre du bus le sommet un signe plus
efficace que tous les mots en un instant
le poids de l'attenté de l'anxiété
accumulée ces derniers jours se brise
dans un débordement de joie intense
mais comme le reconnaissent cette
victoire étant bien des sens une
victoire partagée non seulement par les
grimpeurs et les porteurs qui l'ont
rendu possible mais également par toutes
les expéditions précédentes parce qu'ils
ont tracé les itinéraires et qui ont été
les premiers à utiliser les techniques
par les hommes qui ont conquis le col
nord en veste de laine et en culotte de
golf qui se sont attaqués à l'arête nord
sous les coups de semonce du mousson
précoce des hommes qui resteront à
jamais dans toutes les mémoires non pour
leur échec mais pour leurs exploits et
reculer
en 1948 eric shipton avait écrit céline
prophétique il est possible et même
probable que dans quelque temps les
hommes se souviendront de nos ridicules
et fort sans comprendre nos échecs
répétés à l'arc ils seront confrontés à
des problèmes autrement plus important
si nous sommes encore en vie
il ne fait nul doute que nous
promènerons vigoureusement dans nos
barbes blanches pour tenter de justifier
notre faiblesse
mais si nous avons atteint la sagesse
nous nous souviendrons avec gratitude
que nous avons saisi à pleines mains les
opportunités qui se présentaient à nous
et nous nous réjouirons d'observer les
jeunes générations en faire de même
et